sparate lì a sti bastardi ammazzateli
tutti sparate lì tutti ma trova qualcuno
che ti trombi e vattene affanculo
con questa feccia di gentaglia [ __ ] non
si scherza
miss ucraina si scopa fino in fondo e si
dà un calcio nel sedere camera a gas
subito parassiti di merda e andare a
prenderla a calci in culo non ci hai
pensato
questa non è una donna è una squallida
cagna qui sei l'unico grosso obeso
bimbominkia secchione di merda faccia di
merda brutte lesbiche meritate la
fucilazione
il ladro truffatore e di [ __ ]
che li inseguono a me gli immigrati
fanno schifo
quelli che ho conosciuto sono gente di
merda faccia di merda non sai un cazzo e
prendi a me per imbecille rotto in culo
e merdoso parole dure vero parole che
sono come dei cazzotti nello stomaco per
ognuno di noi e lo sono ancora di più
perché queste sono parole vere questi
sono post presi realmente dalla rete
le parole sono la chiave fatata che apre
ogni porta le parole sono importanti
proprio per questa ragione è veramente
importante usarle bene usarle con
consapevolezza e quando questo non
accade
possiamo fare finta di non vedere oppure
no perché ognuno di noi può fare
veramente la differenza e gente come noi
quasi due anni fa ha provato a farla ha
provato a fare la differenza provato a
disegnare un percorso nuovo
una persona come noi rosi russo creativa
di trieste madre di quattro figli
particolare non da poco nella storia che
vi sto per raccontare davanti a un
crescente disagio nel suo stare in rete
ha provato a dire io non ci sto deve
esserci un modo diverso per stare in
rete e ha provato a usare il potere
forte della condivisione ha condiviso
tutto questo il suo disagio con le
persone che erano più vicino a lei le
persone della sua rete e in una calda
sera d'agosto
prima di andare in vacanza forse il
caldo era tanto ha mandato 100 email
cento email a persone di estrazione
completamente diversa ritenevano ne
sarebbe tornata nemmeno una in questa e
mail condividevo il suo disagio
condivideva la sua volontà di provare a
fare la differenza a trovare un modo
diverso per stare in rete
beh di queste 100 email ne sono tornate
indietro 99 solo una non ha avuto
risposta
e queste persone con estrazioni diverse
ma con un unico comune denominatore la
passione la voglia di fare la differenza
persone che erano come noi docenti
influencer blogger manager della
comunicazione hanno cominciato a pensare
come si potesse trovare una nuova strada
e questa è stata la genesi di parole
ostili un progetto sociale di
sensibilizzazione contro la violenza
delle parole queste persone hanno
cominciato a pensare a dei principi e
questa è stata la nascita i primi passi
del manifesto della comunicazione non lo
stile loro queste persone queste persone
che venivano dalla rete hanno messo
insieme 250 principi questi 250 principi
sono diventati poi vinti tre principi
sono stati messi ancora una volta in
rete perché tutto questo nasce in rete e
per la rete sono stati messi in
votazione in rete eravamo nel gennaio
del 2017
e pensate che in quindici giorni sono
arrivati oltre
17 mila voti sicuramente un primo forte
segnale che forse parole ostili stava
accogliendo un desiderio un bisogno
forte nel nostro paese
dopodiché ci ritroviamo al 17 febbraio
del 2017
il giorno in cui davanti a una platea di
1.200 persone giornalisti politici
blogger influencer manager della
comunicazione veramente una platea molto
trasversale davanti enrico mentana e
molti altri personaggi ma soprattutto
davanti a gianni morandi che oltre 50
anni fa aveva già fatto il suo manifesto
dell'amore con un mondo d'amore suo
grande hit di molti anni fa persona
straordinaria per come sta in rete
soprattutto su facebook
beh davanti a tutto questo è nato il
manifesto della comunicazione non ostile
eccolo lo leggiamo insieme virtuale e
reale dico o scrive in rete solo cose
qui al coraggio di dire di persona si è
ciò che si comunica le parole che scelgo
raccontano la persona che sono mi
rappresentano le parole danno forma al
pensiero mi prendo tutto il tempo
necessario esprimere al meglio quel che
penso prima di parlare bisogna ascoltare
nessuno ha sempre ragione
neanche io ascolto con onestà e apertura
le parole sono un ponte scelgo le parole
per comprendere farmi capire avvicinarmi
agli altri le parole hanno conseguenze
so che ogni mia parola può avere
conseguenze piccole o grandi condividere
è una responsabilità
condivido testi e immagini solo dopo
averli letti valutati compresi le idee
si possono discutere le persone si
devono rispettare non trasformo chi
sostiene opinioni che non condivido in
un nemico da annientare gli insulti
non sono argomenti non accetto insulti
aggressività nemmeno a favore della mia
tesi anche il silenzio comunica quando
la scelta migliore tacere taccio
vedete che questi sono principi lo
sottolineo questi sono principi questi
non sono regole perché non servono
regole per riuscire veramente a fare la
differenza per trovare uno stile diverso
per stare in rete per cambiare un
pochettino la nostra vita perché devono
essere dei principi che noi sentiamo
sulla nostra pelle nel nostro sangue che
possiamo applicare in ogni momento della
nostra vita che sia online o che sia
offline ma soprattutto devono essere
semplici e dietro questa semplicità c'è
un enorme lavoro perché devono essere
semplici perché devono essere compresi
da tutti per essere portati ovunque
anche dai bambini
beh da quel 17 febbraio è passato poco
più di un anno ed è stato un viaggio
straordinario
pensate che la star parole ostili e
quindi stiamo parlando solo di twitter
ha raggiunto ad oggi oltre 25 milioni di
persone
lo sottolineo perché chi mastica un
pochettino di numeri digitali sa
perfettamente che questo è un numero che
va molto oltre la sola platea repubblica
italiano e questo nonostante l'astag sia
in italiano
ogni volta che parole ostili ha lanciato
un nuovo tema o un nuovo evento è stato
twitta tissimo dalla community ancora
una volta su twitter ad oggi in solo un
anno parole ostili è stato già sei volte
trending topic
il manifesto è stato inviato a tutte le
scuole d'italia e all'inaugurazione
dell'anno scolastico
il presidente mattarella ha donato e
ragazzi presenti all'evento di
inaugurazione e 500 la costituzione e il
manifesto della comunicazione non ostile
il manifesto è stato presentato a 30.000
studenti e ha visto il coinvolgimento
attivo di 15.000
ma non solo le cose succedono talmente
velocemente che i numeri si evolvono
costantemente il manifesto è stato
tradotto fino a due giorni fa in 12
lingue che sono già diventate 14 perché
si è aggiunto anche il cinese e
giapponese
ma la cosa importante è che è stato
tradotto spontaneamente perché tranne le
prime due lingue l'inglese tedesco che
sono state fatte dal team di volontari
di parole ostili è stato tradotto da
tutte le persone che hanno ritenuto che
manifesto potesse essere una bussola nel
proprio paese e devo dire stiamo
coprendo ormai qualsiasi territorio a
livello internazionale ma è importante
anche sottolineare che il manifesto è
stato tradotto anche in latino e greco e
penso che sia veramente una cosa
speciale che un manifesto dei principi
per il mondo alla fine digitale perché
da lì siamo nati siano tradotti anche
nelle lingue antiche un fantastico
esempio davvero del mondo a due velocità
in cui viviamo
il manifesto è stato anche pubblicato è
quindi entrato nella maggior parte delle
famiglie italiane anche su topolino
testata che ha 80 anni testata cartacea
anche in questo caso un po mondo a due
velocità ed è anche l'oggetto di una
partnership molto importante perché è il
focus di una partership con il miur il
ministero dell'università della ricerca
e l'università cattolica del sacro cuore
proprio per portarla in tutte le scuole
d'italia con un percorso civico digitale
veramente molto importante ed è bello
che istituzioni come queste abbiano
saputo cogliere un bisogno in questa
direzione lo stiano supportando in modo
davvero molto importante e proprio
nell'ambito di questa partnership il 9
febbraio si è tenuto un evento che non
esito a definire epocale perché 1400
insegnanti da tutta italia sono arrivati
all'università cattolica del sacro cuore
per una giornata di formazione gratuita
organizzata da parole ostili giornata
che ha visto il coinvolgimento di trenta
panel 80 relatori
tutto questo davanti al ministro
valeria fedeli al presidente della rai
maggioni ma anche a gherardo colombo ex
distratto che ha fatto un intervento un
percorso meraviglioso con 500 studenti
con i quali ha fatto un viaggio dalla
costituzione al manifesto della
comunicazione non ostile ma non solo in
quella giornata è stato condiviso anche
un lavoro didattico davvero mastodontico
perché sono state presentate 100 schede
didattiche frutto della collaborazione
del supporto del lavoro di 250
insegnanti che da ottobre dell'anno
scorso hanno voluto supportarci in
questo percorso schede didattiche che
sono un vero e proprio una vera propria
cassetta degli attrezzi per riuscire a
portare il manifesto dal giorno dopo in
tutte le scuole di ogni ordine e grado
in ogni materia con un lavoro
estremamente estremamente specifico beh
io penso però che un percorso di questo
genere non può assolutamente tralasciare
la comunicazione che ritengo sia la più
stile che ci sia
parlo ovviamente della comunicazione
politica e per questa ragione a dicembre
parole ostili ha lanciato cambio stile
una richiesta di presa di coscienza di
presa di responsabilità ai nostri
politici per affrontare una campagna
elettorale delle elezioni a soli tre
mesi dal d day con un obiettivo
differente mettere al centro di tutto la
forza delle proposte la forza delle idee
e non la forza degli insulti
beh devo dire che l'adesione è stata
straordinaria perché più di 350 politici
hanno sottoscritto questo impegno non ha
sottoscritto il loro impegno tra loro
sette ministri tra i governatori una
quindicina di sindaci vi devo dire stata
emozionante ricevere una bellissima
lettera di supporto del presidente
gentiloni
ma la cosa più importante ancora è che
tutto questo è venuto in modo
assolutamente trasversale perché
l'adesione è stata di tutte le forze
politiche
la cosa fondamentale però è una bene mi
prendo la responsabilità mi prendo un
impegno andiamo a vedere che cosa è
successo dopo
per cui all'inizio di febbraio con la
collaborazione dell'istituto di ricerca
ipsos
abbiamo lanciato un monitoraggio il
termometro di parole ostili pubblicato
sul corriere della sera ogni settimana a
cinque settimane dalle elezioni che è
andato a misurare la percezione degli
italiani relativamente alla campagna per
quello che riguardava l'indice di
aggressività l'indice di falsità e
combinando i due indici l'indice di
ostilità mi piacerebbe essere molto
disdegna né in questo momento e potervi
raccontare una storia a lieto fine ma
non è andata così
avete visto le avete visto la campagna
elettorale non è la campagna elettorale
meno ostile che ci ricorderemo o che
abbiamo visto negli ultimi anni ma in
ogni caso io credo che sia stato un
passaggio importantissimo un passaggio
dovuto che sicuramente ci darà una
direzione differente per il futuro
io potrei andare avanti veramente a
raccontarvi ancora tantissime cose
perché il viaggio che parole ostili che
questo manifesto ha fatto insieme a
tutti quelli che lo stanno supportando è
stato straordinario e ha portato il
manifesto in tanti ambiti l'ambito
dell'educazione abbiamo visto alcune
cose insieme
l'ambito della politica ma anche
l'ambito dell'azienda e l'ambito della
pubblica amministrazione però voi vi
farete una domanda ma tutto questo io
che c'entro
perché vi sto raccontando tutto questo
cosa faccio qui
beh capita che un giorno dopo trent'anni
di vita da manager in azienda
senti che non stai vivendo la vita che
vuoi vivere
scettiche il mondo aziendale che vik i
vivi non ti assomiglia per niente e
senti anche che la confort zona i
benefit gli status symbol non bastano
più a colmare il vuoto
e allora decide di mollare tutto e sento
che è arrivato il momento di provare a
restituire quello che tu hai ricevuto
provare a fare la differenza provare ad
essere il cambiamento che vorresti
vedere avvenire nel mondo e in tutto
questo
vedi trovi il seme nascente di parole
ostili e senti che è esattamente quello
che vuoi vivere dentro di te e quindi
pensi che ci deve c'è un altro modo di
vivere la vita
c'è un altro modo e decidi di provare a
percorrere lo fai
guardando negli occhi tua figlia di 15
anni e sperando di poter essere il
cambiamento nella vita nel mondo che noi
stiamo disegnando per il domani
per loro da allora sono passati quasi
due anni e ho fatto delle scoperte
meravigliose innanzitutto ho incontrato
delle persone fantastiche persone che si
mettono in discussione ogni giorno
persone che hanno una passione
straordinaria persone che hanno voglia
di dedicarsi agli altri ed è fantastico
tutto questo dopo che per 30 anni in
azienda ti hanno raccontato che le
persone sono numeri
ho anche imparato che a sognare non si
sbaglia che a volte i sogni sembrano
molto grandi ma a volte si avverano lo
stesso ho imparato anche che ognuno di
noi può fare la differenza e può essere
il motore di piccole rivoluzioni che
possono diventare delle grandi
rivoluzioni e ho anche imparato che sono
una persona incredibilmente fortunata
perché fare ciò che ami e libertà amare
ciò che fai e felicità grazie
[Applauso]